Welcome back. Today we're taking a close look at a recent YouTube
video from Destiny where he discusses the ongoing legal case
Pixiev. Bonnel will compare his onstream statements with the
actual court filings to get a clearer picture. Let's begin.
For again, I don't know how I don't know how I've like hooked
up with people and done stuff for like the past decade. And it
was only in the past year that I've had so many like insanely
disgusting and unhinged women who have just decided that apparently
I'm a for everything I've done is like non-conentual who have
just started dumping a ton of my not safe for work content online.
Even if Destiny wins the case, this is far from the first time
Destiny has liked nudes. He's done it to his ex-wife among other
women. He's also assaulted a woman on stream. So acting like
Destiny is a abuser is actually the appropriate way to treat
him. I was like, "What do you got to say about these logs? I
heard um I found out that you leaked nudes of a girl." It's like,
"Dude, there have been threads on this. This has been in the
news." Like, everybody knows this, dude. You're not finding out
anything new about me. Like, understood that you showed private
pictures of her to two of your friends. Yes.
Okay. So, that's part of it. In 2012, when Destiny was 23, he
shared in a group chat with a couple of his friends the messages,
"You want to see the sickest in the world? So many fan girls.
I had one that was 15. She wanted to meet and hook up. Dude,
she's 15. What the?" But she sent me pictures that made it so
hard to say no. Then Destiny linked a picture of this girl in
a bikini in the chat and said, "Girl on the left, so hard to
say no. gonna get arrested one of these MLGs. Man, I'm gonna
go into detail or anything, but there's plenty of people that's
wondering this, but I feel like it should be obvious. Um, nothing
has happened with consent with anyone. Not me, not anyone else.
Like, like there's been no consent. So, that's something that
people seem to wonder about and I feel like that's something
that people should know. I guess that's it. Oh, anyone saying
stuff like that, that's like actual revenge. Um, so no, thank
you. It's it's not anything like that. So, thank you. That's
something else that happened. Um,
yeah, that was really horrible. Actually really horrible. I take
it very seriously. Um, so anyone commenting about that stuff
because it's an actual traumatic experience, they're going to
they're going to get instantly and never run out of a long time
ago. So sometimes, so obviously, okay, me and Lena send news
to people. Um, me and had a conversation about there were a few
girls we talked to. I was like, "Oh, cool. Like we should record
videos of like us send people like it's fun." So we do this.
Um, I kind of like have like my little archive of like material
that I'll send to people if I want to. Um, there were girls that
I talked to um, past that that I'd send stuff of like either
me or me and Molina. And Molina talked to me and she was like,
"Hey, um, if you're going to send any videos to um, new girls
that we haven't talked about, like, let me know that first."
Um, because she wanted to be careful. Okay, sure. That's fine.
I didn't think of it at the time cuz I didn't think it mattered.
But if you're going to send any videos to um, new girls that
we haven't talked about, like, let me know that first. Um, because
she wanted to be careful. Okay, sure. That was fine. I didn't
think of it at the time cuz I didn't think it mattered. But I
didn't think of it at the time cuz I didn't think it mattered.
Around the end of 2011, Destiny assaulted a woman on his live
stream. I'm not using the word allegedly here because we have
video of him doing it and he has openly admitted that it was
assault. I would say that in my streaming career in the past,
like totally publicly like I completely and totally like assaulted
a girl on stream before for like 5 minutes or whatever. I got
super drunk.
This case is over. This will be my hopefully my last manifesto
ever.
But um
when I do when I do the manifesto, when
read through everything,
I'm going to take Is there like a drug that makes you cry? I
need to like watch the saddest movies
of animals and cats dying. What's that one with the the anime
with the little girl that's dead at the end and the war [__]
or whatever? Oh, Grave of the
Destiny opens dramatically declaring this case is over and then
muses about needing to induce tears with sad movies like Grave
of the Fireflies to convey the supposed horror of the violations.
This case is over statement is immediately questionable. Court
records, specifically Pacer entries 74,75 and 76 from May 19th,
2025 show the case is very much active. A hearing on Pixie's
motion for preliminary injunction was scheduled for June 3rd,
and the court was actively ruling on various motions. The talk
of needing to artificially cry seems like a performance, an appeal
to a motion rather than a factual address of the legal situation.
It suggests a focus on the appearance of distress.
So, for we're not spending too much time today. for those that
haven't kept up. Um,
uh, I can't show you the transcript or read from it directly,
I think, because,
uh, the opposition moved to seal the transcript immediately because
they didn't want it to be publicly available. Uh, because stuff
that you say under oath matters and she would rather spam tweets
and stuff about me where she can lie with impunity or just say
random. I guess
Destiny here claims he can't show or read from the hearing transcript
because he alleges Pixie's side moved to seal the transcript
immediately to prevent public knowledge, arguing that stuff that
you say under oath matters and she would rather spam tweets and
stuff about me where she can lie with
While parties can move to seal transcripts, Destiny's framing
is telling. Transcripts, especially from preliminary hearings,
often get sealed to protect sensitive information, details about
witnesses, or evidence that might later be ruled inadmissible,
not necessarily, as he implies, to allow one party to lie with
impunity. Pixie herself is proceeding under a pseudonym granted
by a protective order, as seen in documents 3 and 7 due to the
case's sensitive nature.
Her team wanting to seal a transcript containing her testimony
would be consistent with that. Interestingly, Pixie's team in
document 73, paragraphs 8 and 9, accuses Destiny himself of publicly
discussing the case, allegedly revealing confidential details
and even allegedly doxing Pixie in violation of a court order.
His accusation here seems like an attempt to deflect from his
own alleged public
One of the things that came out, a lot of things came out during
the hearing we had. And one of the things that came out
she admitted that her and her lawyers had seen absolutely no
evidence from the Abby person that I'd ever sent her any material
relating to Pixie ever. Uh, which tracks with what I when I went
back and my like I've never sent this person anything of her
ever.
So, I'm pretty sure she's just lying.
But one thing I didn't even factor in or think of
is she might not actually be lying in that way
cuz I didn't know this at the time. I didn't figure this out
or I didn't learn of this until a few months ago.
And now I've learned a little bit more. This person was um
this person was the the Abby MC whoever that is. This person
was at my house
and it is possible that they might have known about stuff on
my computer
because when they were at my house, apparently when I was away
from my computer, they were going through my [__]
And um
now I've had people send me a few things and I can see that that
was in fact the case that she was sending people pictures and
stuff of like my desktop when I I don't know where I was or I
don't even know what the I was doing at the time but apparently
she was. So I don't know. I actually have no idea what she has
or hasn't seen on my computer or if she found a way to download
this or send it to herself or some just in my mind it wouldn't
even factor that
somebody do anything. And then um I missed this initially, but
in her messages to Darius,
I don't even want the money. What he's doing slash has done seems
I've seen all the drives and all the tapes. So this makes it
sound like she just went through I guess all of my folders and
I don't know what she thinks she saw or what she did see or whatever.
But
this is um I I understand I guess better now I guess where her
testimony comes from. How she could have sent any messages a
long time ago. But the So, it's funny because this entire lawsuit
is only kept alive because of this one person who I don't think
I ever sent anything to and who was probably on my computer without
permission like scrolling through or going through like anything
that I had there. So, that's uh Destiny asserts that at the hearing
Pixie and her lawyers admitted having seen absolutely no evidence
from the Abbeby person that I'd ever sent her any material relating
to Pixie ever. He then offers a new theory. ABMC was at his house,
accessed his computer without permission, and might have seen
or downloaded materials that way. He also references a message
from ABMC to someone named Darius, stating, "I've seen all the
drives and all the tapes."
His conclusion is that the lawsuit is only kept alive because
of this one person who I don't think I ever sent anything to
and who was probably on my computer without permission.
First, Destiny is recounting his version of what happened at
a hearing for which he claims the transcript is sealed. Without
it, his summary is unverified. His new theory about ABMC going
through his is a significant shift. While a serious accusation
against AbbyMC, if true, it also serves to discredit her and
deflect from the central allegation whether Destiny non-consensually
shared Pixie's video.
This is particularly relevant because ABMC's testimony is critical
for Pixie to establish subject matter jurisdiction under the
CDI Act, which requires the sharing to have occurred after October
1, 2022.
Bonel's core defense as seen in his opposition document 42 and
his later opposition to supplemental evidence document 100 is
that any sharing he did was before this crucial date.
What's more, Destiny's own lawyers in document 100 acknowledged
that Pixie is trying to submit a text message from Abby MC dated
November 3, 2023, ECF number 861, where Abby MC claims Bonnel
just sent me another one video of Pixie. This directly contradicts
Destiny's new YouTube theory that Abby MC only got information
by
His own legal team's filings confirm Pixie is trying to prove
he sent it to Abby MC within the statutory time frame. The Darius
message about seeing drives and tapes is vague and could support
either narrative. Destiny is also conveniently playing the victim
here, painting himself as wronged by Abby MC's alleged snooping,
diverting from his own alleged actions, which is why you have
a bunch of um people like Kelly or Dil anything else um who are
now saying like, "Oh, like where's the proof that like this was
or where's the pro?" It's like why why am I going to answer any
questions relating to my personal life? Like for a lot of the
stuff that's been dumped, like nobody's even making an like any
accusations here. This is just stuff that like these disgusting
women have decided to dump online and are now like like I'm sorry
you like off yourself in a video game. Quit your video game.
But
he repeats that AbbyMC can't prove he sent her the video and
claims Pixie already admitted under oath that they had not seen
any evidence whatsoever of him sending AbbyMC anything. He suggests
Pixie's team knows it's bull and is pushing to trial merely to
humiliate him.
Again, these are unverified claims about testimony from a sealed
hearing. And critically, he's ignoring Pixie's active attempts
to submit evidence, specifically the November 3, 2023 text message
from Abby MCX number 861 referenced in Bonel's own document 100,
which does allege Destiny sent her a video within the required
time frame. His lawyers are in fact fighting the admission of
this very piece of
Attributing malicious motives like humiliation to Pixie is a
classic
Hen your PC password. Was it already unlocked? I doubt it was
locked. I just I don't know when I left that person at my house
alone. I don't know. I don't It's that was a long time ago. It
was like 2 years ago. So, I'm not even sure trying to remember.
He claims he doesn't recall if his PC was locked when Abby MC
was supposedly at his house alone, stating this was like 2 years
ago.
His vagueness about PC security is convenient for his snooping
theory. If AbbyMC was at his house 2 years ago from the June
2025 perspective of the video, so around mid 2023, this timing
could actually align with the November 3, 2023 text message Pixie
is trying to introduce where ABMC claims Destiny just sent me
another one. It doesn't neatly support his snooping instead of
sending
Why not go with the implied consent from the start of the drama?
let me think of
I think I already admitted as much under
uh under when we were doing the hearing the 100% the honest valid
truth and if I get to ever read the testimony
Pixie yaps so much it it was honestly it was so helpful for me.
Um the honest truth is like these are conversations that happened
like over 5 years ago right? I don't remember exactly the conversations
that we had at the time. There's just no way I'm going to be
able to honestly say like, "Oh yeah, we said this and this and
this and this." When there's no like text log of anything, there's
no way. Um, but the the way that she talked about it and the
way that she explained it actually tracked really well for me.
Um, but it's hard to recount all that without just reading it
entirely. So hopefully one day the uh the transcript becomes
um available. We'll see, I guess, when they finally roll out.
Destiny brings up implied consent and says he doesn't remember
exact conversations from over 5 years ago regarding Pixie.
Implied consent is a legal argument the court will assess. Pixie's
filings, like document 4, strongly assert she did not consent
to wider distribution, and the original complaint, document one,
details discussions about privacy.
His claim of not remembering specifics from over 5 years ago
is inaccurate for this situation. The video with Pixie was recorded
on September 12, 2020, document 1, paragraph 11, which is less
than 5 years from June 2025.
This timeline error, intentional or not, could be an attempt
to make the event seem more vaguely memorable.
So, what happens now with the court stuff? Um, it's just a it's
just the same as before. Just waiting waiting waiting for a summary
judgement. Technically, discovery ends in December. So, there's
a question of like, would we wait until December to file a summary
judgement? I doubt we'll wait that long. Hopefully not. Um, we
could file for summary judgement after the first round of discovery,
I guess, because they're not going to get anything from me. At
this point, I don't even know what my obligations are to turn
anything over because, to be honest, I don't trust them to turn
anything honestly over. I don't trust Pixie. I fully believe
that her and Lauren and anybody else that is like scheming with
her would lie about what they turn over and I don't think I would
get everything. I actually have really good reasons to believe
this that I can't reveal right now. Um, but I will after the
end of the trial. Um,
but the, um, yeah, I don't think they're going to turn over anything,
uh, that would be relevant to me that that I would be asking
for anyway. So,
so ideally, I guess if like nobody's really requesting anything
else for discovery, and if nobody else is um, like subpoenaing
anything, there's no other information coming out, then you basically
can file for a summary judgement hopefully. But there's also
the um there's also hopefully the chance this I think this is
slimmer my but there's a chance that the magistrate judge
dumps the um whole case because of the lack of subject matter
jurisdiction. But that's it's not technically his role and that's
not technically a question before him. But the subject matter
jurisdiction question was coming up a lot in our last hearing
and now it's showing up in motion. So hopefully he makes some
statement about that.
he discusses the case's progression, mentioning discovery, summary
judgement, and his hope that the magistrate judge dumps the whole
case because of the lack of subject matter jurisdiction.
Subject matter jurisdiction is a key defense for Bonel against
the federal CDI Act claim. If Pixie can't prove he shared the
video after October 1, 2022, that federal claim is in jeopardy.
This is precisely why Pixie is fighting to admit ABMC's declaration
and the November 3, 2023 text message, they are her attempt to
establish that later sharing by Destiny.
While a magistrate judge makes recommendations on such dispositive
issues, the district judge usually makes the final call. And
even if the federal claim is dismissed, Pixie has state law claims,
cyber harassment, invasion of privacy, IED as per document 1,
paragraph 2. The court could keep these or dismiss them for refiling
in state court. A dismissal of the federal claim doesn't mean
the entire legal fight is over. A nuance destiny omits.
His assertion that he doesn't trust Pixie to turn anything honestly
over is an unsubstantiated claim designed to cast doubt.
What do you think they'll try to request me? Um, it's just like
logs and or whatever, but like the stuff they're looking for
just doesn't exist. Is the problem. like they want like what
they really want to desperately see is the idea that I'm like
they're praying for me having like sent you know her video or
other stuff around to a bunch of people but like it just it doesn't
exist. They're they're praying for some kind of evidence to to
keep the case alive because the case is basically
it has been like dead on arrival and then dead for quite a while.
But yeah,
but pretty annoying.
Destiny claims the evidence Pixie seeks just doesn't exist because
he didn't widely share her video, reiterating the case is dead
on arrival.
This is a self-serving denial. The court's active management
of the case with hearings and rulings on motions like those regarding
sealed witness declarations shows it's far from dead. His lawyers
are actively engaged. Documents 99 and 100. He again ignores
his alleged admission to Pixie about sharing the video with Rose.
Document 1, paragraph 16. The current fight over ABMC is about
establishing a later instance of sharing for jurisdictional
Have you seen how they are framing your opposition to the motion
to order KF to take down the videos as you fight me to keep them
up? Kelly was saying that last night and representing the court
order is also taking down your other vids, which I believe it
explicitly wasn't asking. Kelly lies about almost everything.
Um, Kelly and Jessica and them are like remember they talking
about me almost every single day and they constantly lie about
basically everything having to do with this case.
but the um the issue that I had with the court order is one,
it's the Kiwi Farms is not related to our case. So, there's like
almost no incentive for me to even let that court order go through
because why why are you trying to court order a nonparty? Number
one. And number two, um they were asking me for lawyers fees
for their court order. Number three, they wouldn't agree to add
all of my explicit content to that court order. They only wanted
to take down videos of Pixie. They wouldn't even they wouldn't
even ask to take down videos of other women involved. Like it
was the most disgusting like morally bankrupt, unhinged, gross
request I've ever seen in my entire life. So no, absolutely.
He addresses accusations that he's fighting to keep the videos
up on Kiwi Farms. He states his objections were because Kiwi
Farms is a nonparty. Pixie's team sought lawyers fees from him
for the order, and they only wanted to remove videos of Pixie,
not his other explicit content or videos of other women, calling
this disgusting, like morally bankrupt.
A party can have valid legal objections to the method or scope
of a court order. Objecting to an order against a nonparty like
Kiwi Farms without proper procedure or to paying opposing council's
fees are standard legal tactics. His claim that Pixie's team
only wanted her videos taken down from Kiwi Farms is interesting.
If true, it shows Pixie's team focusing on her specific harm
in her lawsuit, which is their right.
Destiny frames this as morally bankrupt because they weren't
also trying to help him or other women whose content might be
on Kiwi Farms. This is a deflection. Pixie isn't obligated to
expand her lawsuit to cover everyone else. Her motion for a TTRO
preliminary injunction, documents 4 and 21, does ask for Bonel
to be compelled to direct third parties to remove her video.
If the magistrate judge tosses the case for lack of jurisdiction
or whatever, does that mean plaintiff can refile? Um, well, she
couldn't refile on the federal claims, so she'd have to refile
a state case. But all of their underlying state charges are and
unhinged. They like require malicious intent to humiliate or
demean, and it's it's stupid.
Destiny correctly notes that if the federal claim is dismissed,
Pixie could refile state claims. He then dismisses these state
claims using victimizing language and unhinged and claims they
require malicious intent to humiliate or
His language is self- serving to show him as a victim. Regarding
state law, Pixie claims Florida statute section
for cyber harassment invasion of privacy IED as per document
1 paragraph 2 have specific elements.
For example, the cyber harassment statute, as cited in Pixie's
TTRO motion documents 421, requires intent to cause substantial
emotional distress, not necessarily malicious intent to humiliate
or demean, though these could overlap. IED requires extreme and
outrageous conduct and intent to cause or reckless disregard
of emotional distress. Destiny's characterization is an oversimplification
likely to downplay the viability of these state claims.
So, when we compare Destiny's YouTube narrative to the actual
court filings, a pattern emerges. Selective storytelling, attempts
to discredit accusers and witnesses, and a framing of legal issues
that often favors his perspective while omitting contrary facts
or nuances present in the official record. The legal battle,
particularly around subject matter jurisdiction and the admissibility
of evidence concerning ABMC, is clearly intense and ongoing.